riley mao is here riley mao how you
doing brother
good all right man um
you know it's been a while and people
been asking about you and uh i just
wanted to know
what um the last we heard from you
you had a love in your life and you had
come across some love
and do you remember that i do okay good
and um and tell me about that the girl
madison was her name
and you guys uh and it kind of fizzled
quickly i remember is that something i'm
recollecting well or no
you're right okay and uh take me through
a little bit of that you guys had
how many dates did you go on uh just one
okay okay and it
uh and then after that what happened
uh things just didn't work out between
us so we just
we just uh she went back to a different
state
and we just never saw each other again
and when you say that things didn't work
out what does it mean because you really
felt
i felt like you were into this gal i was
indeed
um but you know hey things happen
like what i mean
i mean i don't want to get into too much
detail obviously um
but i mean it just i mean she basically
just
saw another guy she was interested in
another guy really
and did you ever meet this guy no no
he's he's in a
in the her state as well so
oh it's easy yeah so she's taking the
easy way out kind of
hitting on some a local guy yep
yeah i hate when chicks do that oh he's
in he lives in my state i'm gonna i'm
gonna hook up with him you know
um what um
what how what else been going on how and
has how has love treated you since then
has there
been anything new on the low of horizon
not yet but um but i you will be the
first to know
what when something happens oh okay
nothing has happened no not yet okay
and how uh how were your holidays did
you enjoy it did you do something what
did you guys do
you guys go to hawaii no my parents did
they're
they're there right now oh wow yeah they
they left me there
and they actually left me in california
um
went to hawaii and um now i'm here and
you guys celebrate christmas
yes that's awesome man good i'm glad
you got to adapt man um
what else man what else can uh what else
do we need to know i know it's been a
while
and i'm glad that you're here now and
i'm glad to be able to check in with you
um do you do you
have you been alive what have you been
what is going on
have i been alive yeah yeah i've been
alive
okay and what else man give me a little
bit more than that give me
have you been outdoors you've been
indoors um i've kind of been staying a
little endorsed just
because of uh covid okay um and is that
fear hitting your community a lot are a
lot of people going down
no everyone's like just saying screw it
let's go outside
do vietnamese people get covered a lot
or no
i have no idea
okay keeping it close to the vest
um riley mao you'll be uh you're
you'll be in uh the um christmas town
extravaganza
i will be exciting
exciting i'm excited to see that man and
i'm grateful that um
that you pop back in and i'm grateful
that you know hopefully we'll hear from
hear more from you what kind of ladies
if there's a lady out there
that really fancies a man like yourself
you know a small
you know not small but a still-growing
maturing
uh malleable you know uh eastern kind of
you know western kind of eastern man
what what type of woman do you think
does would deserve a man like you or is
a good woman
um i'm not i'm not a guy
to be too picky um i mean just
someone that you know treats a guy right
simple as that do you feel like there's
did madison leave you feeling like there
aren't good women out there or did you
did it leave you hopeful or hope less
did you feel like
it it made me hopeful definitely really
that's awesome man and what um
what do you uh do you envision like uh
any future moves or women because that
was your first kiss right right
and do you envision like i'm sure you
started to fantasize oh this is gonna go
to another place like i've done this
with women you know it's like you get
the kiss then you think you're gonna get
you know a double up you know and things
are gonna go crazy and you get all these
crazy you know ideas and you get
sensuality creeps into your body
and next thing you know you just
discussed it with yourself for touching
yourself
but do you uh how did you get
like how did you stop the fantasies and
stuff how did you get away from that
um i mean honestly i just
said or i just thought in my head you
know hey she wasn't the one
move on there's plenty of people out
there
there you go there's plenty of koi in
the pond right there
maybe we'll find you a love out there
riley you never know true
never know what happens and do you have
any other uh
any other words of wisdom
no
riley mal ladies and gentlemen i'm just
sitting
on your front porch wondering how could
i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been